the gyro can experience when you have
all these [ __ ] nut jobs are saying
this is 5g it's uneven a virus it's
radiation sickness someone sent me a guy
that I really like sent me his video of
this doctor that seems like he's got
schizophrenia or something he's talking
about this is a plasma disease caused by
radiation and I'm like oh [ __ ] in Christ
he imagined I've gotten so many people
hitting me up Tim you got to talk about
5g Oh God you know how many people hit
me up when 4G came out
listen 5g is a thing right it's a it's a
new bandwidth for cell phones it's going
to be really fast it's going to be in
your phone so the question is like okay
all this stuff is flying through the air
there's all these signals to the air
what effect do they have on the human
body that's a good question
that's a good question but to say that
that's responsible for this coronavirus
thing it's [ __ ] crazy totally if
you're saying they don't have any effect
and here's why I go okay this is why you
don't need to be worried about UHF or VV
or whatever different waves that are
flying around through the air Wi-Fi and
people are worried about all that kind
of [ __ ] they're really concerned that
this does have some sort of effect on
human beings they think that in fact
cell phone signals have an effect on
bees right that was one of the primary
theories about the drop in bee
populations yeah colony collapse now
these cell phone signals are interfering
with these bees ability to communicate
but to say that it's the [ __ ] corona
virus like Jesus Christ and then someone
had a mean little little Duvall had a
meme that he put up on his Instagram and
I retweeted it
five g's only in five countries you
[ __ ] write this guy [ __ ] has spread
across the whole world he you really
think it's five G it's they I believe
YouTube has to step in and they have to
do something when [ __ ] like that is so
egregious is so preposterous so the
question is where do they draw that line
if it would be nice if they could watch
all your videos and say oh well today
was a really reasonable guy they do okay
but yeah they do they really know that
yeah they do they really literally die
whose doing that yes who is a hundred
percent dedicated to watching everything
you do you put out a lot of [ __ ] kind
I do how much content you put out every
day so if you had to guess ran average
right now as of the past few months up
to about
three three hours and forty minutes per
day so you got a guy it's dedicated at
YouTube his job is what do you do I'm
the Tim pool guy I just so first
probably not like that specific but I do
have a partner manager I do have every
single video I put out on my foot my
mate mama my main channel is reviewed
100% of them on they just recently
introduced my other two channels so I
have I have a total of three channels
under my name where I put out around 10
to 12 separate videos per day for a
total about 3 hours and 40 minutes they
what they do so if I upload a video it
gets reviewed through something so I
first self-certify I say this video has
no swearing it has no you know extreme
and imagery or anything like that if
someone watches it and D monetizes it I
then contact Google and they reverse it
for me so I actually have someone who
fixes this if there's an issue they
watch them they watch every episode they
watch every episode every episode that's
bonkers so you got a guy who that's
there don't think I don't think it's a
Sara Lee one person but a team of freaks
my understanding is it is California
based and so so here's where I look I'm
I think YouTube's a very very awesome
thing I wouldn't have a show I'd be
working I was working for a Disney
Company and I did not like it and I was
able to leave and start my own business
and I'm rather successful with it and
it's because of YouTube and it's because
they view me as trustworthy they you
know I've known them for a long time
they've worked with me it's not perfect
the challenge is fundamental human
rights and the and the collapse of the
media industry when we have news outlets
that so I'll give you an example you
post this on Instagram that people were
calls for poisoning you know disinfected
ingestion had gone up every Tom's
comments right that's not true
it's fake news I fell for two I tweeted
it out I tweeted the George George
Carlin quote the one that's a think
about how stupid the average person is
and realize half of them are stupider
than that sure enough it turns out they
faked the story the real story is that
since the start of the pandemic people
have been buying more cleaner than
normal so statistically with more people
having cleaner
they're more likely now to in accident
just it and since March the calls have
been going up the New York Daily News
one of the main purveyors of the story
tacked on after Donald Trump's comments
unrelated unrelated unrelated so here's
the problem if the Daily News if CNN if
if Fox if MSNBC if these outlets are
going to do these things in a desperate
bid to stay alive as their as their
methodology fails and YouTube is going
to give them preferential access which
is what they've done
then we're in serious trouble but they
don't give the Daily News preference no
like a channel the main networks I don't
think that egregious right here's here's
one that really grossed me out was CNN I
believe they tweeted one of the
reporters at CNN tweeted that Elon Musk
has not supplied all the ventilators
that he promised and then Elon said are
you aware that Twitter has a search
feature and then he starts retweeting
all of these different hospitals showing
the ventilators people thanking him it
has a Tesla logo on it and and and it
was the hospitals are requested them
specifically and they were specific
parameters so you don't CNN did argued
semantics the article that was written
to to prove they were right was that
those aren't ventilators real
ventilators are invasive ventilators
that go in your body and seep at a CPAP
is a ventilate is a ventilator as is a
BiPAP what they're called non-invasive
or not intrusive that's such a [ __ ]
gross way to just decide what you
tweeted and so journalists are supposed
to help you understand what's going on
in them yes not confuse it there the
goal of making money right that's what
that's what it is right
it's about clickbait absolutely you can
clickbait that the smartest man in the
world [ __ ] up and didn't give the
ventilators you want what the scariest
thing is CNN anybody's network anyone
any of these networks can make a fake
story get a million views a day later
apologize retract and they keep all the
money they made they don't got to give
it back so they're actually actively
incentivized I'm not saying they're
sitting there you know trolling a
mustache male like let's write a frank
story but they know that if they do they
get paid and they less so what they're
you know what the fake news gets a
million hits the retraction gets 30k
get paid for both so this is an
editorial review fail where editors are
not reviewing these articles that are
being written by journalists I think
they're all swimming in a toilet
circling you know down to the drain
because what happens is somebody so I
saw story written I think it was an
op-ed for the Washington Post or
something about Trump's alligator moat
as fake news that was never real
alligator moat right right so this story
from 2017 that Trump talked about
putting alligators in a moat around the
southern border or something was like
it's ridiculous but here's what happens
you write a fake story they wrote that
yeah so that was his idea to do that
it's been a while my understanding of
the story was that a source familiar
with you know Trump's thinking said that
Trump had discussed an alligator moat
and I'm like even if Trump did isn't it
obvious it was a joke
they say they run their money go
knocking alligators would it take to
guard the southern border thousand miles
or whatever
[Applause]